foreign
[Music]
first time I heard about these women
were in an article about Black Panther
where they were talking about how the
door milagi were based on real women
which I thought was fascinating but then
it wasn't until I got the script By Dana
Stevens that I really started to
understand who these women were and of
course reading the script was so
enamored by them and then it was coming
on board and then doing an incredible
Deep dive into the research and it's
it's a phenomenal true story yeah it's
insane data is this something you'd
known about for some time uh no I didn't
I I similarly uh heard about it from
Black Panther but I heard also about it
through Maria Bello who shares the story
credit on the movie and she had been in
West Africa and she came back and came
to Viola and said we've got to make a
movie out of this and when I started
looking at the research that had been
sort of gathered so far I was just blown
away like you were how to how can we
have never heard of this how there are
so many stories out there in other
cultures and we are so focused on
ourselves all the time and this was a
story about women who not only were
fighting Wars and fighting men and
winning but they also had political
power in this culture they were they
were in those Council rooms talking
about you know the direction of of their
people and and I just really wanted to
write about them also just looking at
the drawings of them and uh and this
this
culture that we had never seen before in
film I was very excited to write about
women who had this kind of strength and
autonomy where did you even begin to
learn about them because I know like you
know the thing to do is like go to
Wikipedia and I'm guessing that's not
going to be a great resource for this
yeah well um I I would even go on
YouTube and look for just anything like
I watched French videos that were about
them just to to and I couldn't always
understand what they were saying but
just to find the imagery and also I
would I started to look for books on the
side like I I was interested in the the
slave Port of Wida and I found a book
just about Wida and then I would it
would mention the egoji or mention the
Oyo Empire and that's where I found out
about this battle
where the oil who had sort of had their
their you know foot on the neck of the
Dahomey for 70 years they were defeated
by the agoji so I thought okay well
there's a great battle that we can
depict and the I wanted the Goji to be
victorious
um so I just I really looked for any
side connection that I could find and
another big thing that we all felt is
when you're reading the eyewitness
accounts of the egoji you're reading
primarily white men who have an agenda
to enslave people or you know whatever
their whatever their time period agenda
might be you have to
step aside and go that is one point of
view and uh think about who these women
really were that was in the end what I
wanted to do I wanted it to be from
their point of view from now we and then
niska's point of view and what it felt
like day to day to live in this Palace
and to train to be a warrior
there is so much happening here and you
know there's there's these incredible
dramatic scenes then there's these
massive awesome action sequences like
this this is a superhero movie on so
many levels
um but it does make me curious about the
editing because you're pulling off this
Balancing Act between the drama and the
action how do you find that is that you
know it was was there one one you know
um
um one scene that you struggled with the
most like just nailing the tone or was
the whole thing kind of like a constant
back and forth
um
I would say that the the entire film was
it's it's its own challenging Journey
but it was also in some ways editor Joy
because I got to stretch so many muscles
and you know when I read this script I
just fell in love with it so much and
the characters and the journey that they
take and Gina and I talked a lot about
the character Journey but and not just
in those intimate moments which were
really important to land so you the
audience could imprint on these people
and care about them
but carrying the character Journey
Through the the fights themselves you
know the big the big pieces the oil
battle which is like eight minutes of
just pure battle and so for me it was
always keeping that keeping those bones
keeping that the structure of the um
you know the characters through whatever
we were going through I think for me the
hardest one because I knew and since the
audience would it takes sometimes a
moment to know you know for them to
settle in and to kind of have that that
transition from we're sitting down to
watch maybe Viola or the care you know
an actor to where she becomes nanisca
for them where she imprints on them and
I saw in many ways starting the film and
and kind of starting that whole you know
initial rise out of the grass and and
that initial battle because
you know it was really important to you
know sell and and that that these women
were formidable and they were Fierce and
that they worked together but they had
their own you begin to kind of get a
sense of who they were even from the
moment they come out of the grass right
and so that was really challenging but
not because these these women these
actors trained so intensely so for me as
an editor it was wonderful to be able to
allow to show that to show their skill
and
but at the same time it was the first
battle so it was really important that
you know people believe that these that
these women you know were as Fierce and
formidable as they were
and Eugene together since Love and
Basketball I believe so you must have a
nice shorthand at this point yeah yeah I
mean in many ways it was similar I mean
you know with love and basketball you
you needed to believe that that uh you
know that tanar was was about a bivo and
with this one you had to believe that
you know uh Viola and you know and
UNESCO and amenza and zogi and were
Fierce so yeah I mean it's I think the
shorthand it's really a trust I think
it's it's at a where I think we're at a
point where
um
you know
I know what she's looking for we have
lots of conversations you know doing
pre-production and and I think during
production because Gina has so much
going on I mean this film I mean as
someone who's also in the editing room
but also Witnesses the Journey of every
one of these people
um her her her
responsibility on this film was
unbelievable and it was it was a
difficult shoot and so I feel like my
responsibility was just to keep her
informed keep up with them in terms of
what they were doing what they were
about to do if there was something I
could help provide whatever information
they needed based on what I was seeing
in the cut as they you know as she
continued to shoot and just tell them to
keep going because what they were doing
was pretty incredible
uh Terence I heard that this is your
80th film as composer
I don't know
they have people who keep track of those
things
um what did draw you specifically to
this project
oh well first of all it was Gina you
know it's um
you know I worked with her on Love Love
and Basketball
and I've seen the trajectory of her
career just grow exponentially with each
project
and then we did a TV show together
called shots fired
so when she called me to do this
I was excited about it because you know
I just love her work
and then she sent me the script and then
when you read the script it's like come
on
you know I got to be a part of this you
know a black
female King in Africa are you kidding
you know
um because I think
the thing that I love about making
movies is that I've been blessed enough
to work on projects that are pertinent
to the times that we're living in you
know and this movie is so important for
so many reasons you know and I told Gina
this and I and I'll keep saying it
whenever somebody asks me a question
she made the movie that I finally been
waiting to see for a long time
you know I've been waiting to see our
culture shot and put on the big screen
in such a way that was elegant and
respectful and beautiful
and when you look at all of these
performances you know of all of these
brilliant
actors and actresses you know for me it
was just a blessing to be a part of it
and the score is so gorgeous how did you
sort of combine that that classical
orchestral you know epicness while being
so steeped in West African culture and
instrumentation
well I mean you know
it's it's one of those things where you
try to find a balance you know I
remember when I first saw the movie I
was like oh shit don't
don't screw this up you know what I mean
because everything was so beautiful
but I think for me one of the things
that I've always tried to do as a
composer
because I you know and studying like
people like Stravinsky and other great
composers one of the things that they've
always done is take folklore and expound
on it right and that's one of the things
my teachers always talk to me about as a
jazz musician who writes for orchestra
so I wanted to do the same thing with
this film was to take our culture right
and use it within their Orchestra but
expand on it and expound on it to make
it bigger and broader but at the same
time
Universal
so I needed to find some type of melodic
Gene that could fit the bill and man I
was listening to some Ladysmith black
mambaza because I really love their
music and the way they use clustered
Harmony that moves diatonically through
certain
harmonic progressions was the way that I
started and I literally started at the
piano with the bottom but I used a
cluster type of Harmony and that just
set the tone for the entire thing and
once I came up with the entire Melody
you know man you sit in your room by
yourself and you think it's great until
you got to play it for somebody
you know so I sent it to Gina man and I
was a little nervous and uh Gina and her
listen to it and they they gave me the
thumbs up and once they did that and
then it was just full steam ahead and
um I remember when they got when I got
the film
the first scene that I worked on was the
Goji coming back to the kingdom after
the battle
you know because from there's something
about that scene to me that's just
Majestic heroic and just beautiful about
these women who just been through this
fierce battle and they've come they're
coming back to the kingdom that they're
protecting and the people are so
appreciative and so respective of
respectful of what it is that they've
been doing that that needed to be the
moment to set the tone for me for the
rest of the film musically you mean when
they come back at the end no no no no in
the beginning at the beginning the first
after the first battle when the little
boy is trying to oh okay yeah yeah yeah
um Tony and Becky I'm so curious about
trying to recreate the sounds of 1820s
the homie especially when you're
shooting and was probably a modern day
City where you probably got traffic and
helicopters among so many other things
you don't really have access to you know
video of 1820 how did you sort of know
what it should sound like
well I just um I did a lot of research
and just
um listening for the sounds of Africa
and listening for the sounds of the
correct Birds and the correct winds and
doing research on wildlife and making
sure you know Gina talked about having
that that the sounds of animals you know
we don't see a lot of them but they are
there and so when we go through the
jungle we go through different parts
we're hearing
hearing animals and and I was
um
just looking to make a a soundscape of
Africa that was beautiful and the winds
and the bugs and the birds and it was
all so beautiful but then we have the
brutality
of of the the battles and so that you
know that was awesome
I love doing those and uh the sounds of
the machetes and I you know and Maui
when she says you know a rope is not a
weapon and yet later on you know it's a
pretty cool weapon and we have a just a
beautiful sound of that that's so
awesome I love the sound of that rope
and so it's building that Sonic
landscape of of Africa and bringing all
those pieces to the table of of just the
Beauty and the brutality so then I bring
all the pieces to the table and then
Tony's at the table and then he takes
yeah and then we take all those tracks
and we put them in the space that you
you know you're in today and um we have
we have a blast with it
um the the thing in terms of the mix
that we were really focused on was to
make it feel effortless
um take all those elements make it feel
effortless make it feel organic
um really transport you into this world
where we have these Fierce Warriors and
these intense battles and just have that
intensity match what Gina captured on
screen
um and then also with terence's music
make sure that we're playing nice with
terence's music that we're not stepping
on anything and um and just bringing it
all together so we had an amazing time
was there a scene or a moment that was
the most challenging for either of you
both of you yes
[Laughter]
emphatically yes yes
uh there's a scene called the battle
dance oh yes which is uh which was our
Achilles heel through the whole thing
and in the beginning Gina was like we
got to get the battle dance let's get
get that let's get that right and I'm
like we will just give us a little time
it took a lot of time to get it because
um the warriors uh have you know oh
sorry can you talk into the mind sorry
more of a rubber machete right and
they're they're hitting their chests and
they're they're doing their dance and
you know that's a rubber sound hitting
the chest where there's usually a mic
and so there was there were some
challenges in that and take you know
trying to remove the sound
of the impact without hurting the voices
of of the actors and so and I I love
that scene now it's my favorite piece
because we go through that battle dance
and you can hear the grit of their feet
and it's just like it just sounds so
great and the music and everything just
just goes we go from the battle dance
and into the nodes big speech and then
to the the big battle and that's I mean
that that was really challenging just to
get the music and the sound effects and
everything through that to work
correctly together and it does and it
it's
every piece of the puzzle is there
dialogue music sound effects and we all
had to just gel together and and uh we
finally got it
here I was worried about helicopters
overhead I didn't even think about the
actors themselves I couldn't use real
machetes for that part
because there's so many specific details
that are fascinating from you know the
shells to the tribal markings to even
the colors of each tribe
um
yes
um I think uh you know the the research
was um definitely a challenge
um I think we've already alluded to it
before Dana had alluded it to it already
um for us you know I think
um Akim was really helpful for us in
terms of um you know aiding us with that
because he always fed us everything he
was doing because he started before us
and had done quite a bit of research so
I think we started with the book two
missions to geso or something like that
it was like a a amalgamation of essays
that had been written by
um I think he was a captain a missionary
or a missionary and then
um we had of the book
um Amazon's of black Sparta which was
really helpful and that had a lot of
really good descriptions of the uniforms
and so on so you know it was just
weeding through all of these different
things to find
descriptions and things that we could
use and then there were some there's
some illustrations
um that are out there you know know that
the palace tunic that's in the it's red
white and blue
and then the the colors that we ended up
using came basically from the idea one
of the things that was really important
to me in the research was the Indigo and
making sure that we had Indigo in our
costumes it was in our script you know
we had the baths in the scene that now
he sees when she first walks into the
palace and so we really I really wanted
to use Indigo so that was a big thing
and I had started with a skirt that had
a border print and I remember you know
Gina had thought that it wasn't African
enough we we actually thought we had
aced it and this is what we were doing
we put together on a mannequin and you
know had the burgundy tops and so on and
and the skirt and then she looked at it
and the next day she came in and she
said oh I don't think it's African
enough so we had I had some other stuff
that I showed her other Fabrics um that
we had you know found from other
suppliers and and ended up on this skirt
fabric which is a drum print and it's
made by a an artist in from Gambia his
name is Musa and he works by himself
with his son in his yard and made the
skirt made all the skirts for us and we
would get them like in these little
packages coming to us you know week by
week and you know somehow we managed to
put it all together so I think one of
the things for me when I look at the
film is that I noticed that in the
beginning we didn't do as much breakdown
you know because we didn't have enough
fabric for the skirts so you know what I
mean we started you know we were able to
amass what we needed later on but in the
beginning we were really tight so that
went on past research but anyway that's
just a little bit how many people were
you dressing for I can't even imagine
um I don't remember the exact number but
I do remember for us the thing was we
had to be clean and dirty and clean and
dirty because what we were shooting and
so we had probably maybe it was it 40
Warriors maybe in the beginning and you
know so we did like one of the very
first scenes is the rising of the grass
so they're kind of clean then they've
traveled but and then you know we just
went on and it was mostly it was about
the clean dirty thing for us that we
just had to have so much stuff block to
keep it all going so and also I assume
these costumes have to be very practical
because they're doing incredible stunts
in them absolutely absolutely that was
another one of our challenges for sure
making sure that you know everything
stayed on the bodies when they were
fighting
because Gina did have some talks with us
about things that were flying off you
know when they went to fight like their
wet their pieces would would drop off
just you know it's it's it was a very
fast and
um crazy experience the bonamassie I
like when I designed t-shirts I designed
made t-shirts for my crew and one of the
things that's written on them is that we
survived bonamonzi because it was
literally uh like I know we thought like
the Warriors when we were finished I
think yeah
Akeem where did you even begin in
creating this world because I I have
heard this several times Gina said she
really wanted to be a 360 degree
atmosphere for the actors to play in and
immerse themselves which sounds great
but also really hard for you
I mean it was uh it was a beautiful
privilege and a challenge but more
exciting to me is the task of honoring
human beings and looking into a past
that we do not get to see often enough
and to I remember when I was in Benin
this woman Daya in her 20s was my
interpreter she spoke 10 languages they
speak 44 languages in Benin Dahomey is
in modern-day Benin
and she was saying
I wish we had uh uh skyscrapers and I
said but you don't have any fucking
people what are you gonna put in the
skyscraper
she feels like that is a depiction of
success and it's not
and what we did with this film is we
gave you a depiction of something that
is beautiful that is not that and that
is the thing we never see
so you can sleep on the floor with pride
and you can carry things on your head
with pride because that's better than on
your spine that's better for you
sleeping on the floor is better for your
back than sleeping in a soft bed
all these rapping I never in all of my
travels saw a crying baby swaddled to
their mother
there are things that we have forgotten
that we need to remember
and so when Gina allowed us the
privilege of looking into that truth
and giving it back not just to you
but to allow people in Africa to be like
I come from that Village still and it's
beautiful God bless
or let the gods bless
so that's what it was for me is that
every little piece of the things that we
built
needed to be in love with that and us as
creators needed to sit back look listen
and learn because that is beautiful
and again I'm just so curious because
you you had to create all these
different sets in these worlds what was
your biggest challenge
I think I think it is it's it's there's
a burden and feeling passionate about
honoring
and feeling super aware and
self-conscious that that that
these are real this tradition continues
to exist and and that when I step foot
into these spaces I want to be able to
to feel as if I did right by them
so then it's looking at every aspect and
every detail and and saying what is the
magic discovery of that those pieces
like if we're looming how did they Loom
if we're blacksmithing how did they
blacksmith if we're walking and moving
and talking and all of those things how
does that affect the worlds that they're
in so everything has purpose too so we
don't want to put any adornment up that
doesn't have purpose because that is
cultural appropriation when you strip it
of its purpose that is some music video
where someone's dressed up like a Native
American all that stuff has purpose
every bead is sewn on for purpose
so we need to understand that purpose or
not utilize it so that was the beauty is
everything was a discovery of purpose
for me so I'd be like oh man look at
that like the termite Mounds
you'd put the hay on the termite Mound
so the termites come out they eat the
hay and the excretions help waterproof
when you mix that hay with mud and
create your Earthen houses and so some
genius sat and looked at those termite
Mounds it was like it rains and they
never break down I need to figure out
what that is and incorporate it into the
walls of my structures there are
discoveries like that with every little
detail that we created and and what a
what a privilege to discover that
history is beautiful history is
beautiful when you're when you're paying
attention
um again everything in the movie looks
and sounds so terrific I do want to talk
about this amazing cast
um I know Viola was involved as producer
and star but uh your whole ensemble is
is just fantastic some actors you know
we've seen before
um but maybe in ways that we haven't
seen before and then you have you know
this is tuso's first movie which I can't
even believe
um how did you really round out the
entire ensemble yeah
um this group was incredible incredible
group of artists
um in casting I knew I needed to find
um The Warriors that could stand behind
and beside Viola Davis you've got to be
able to go Toe to Toe with Viola Davis
um and also I needed to believe you as a
warrior and believe you in this time and
that was important too I needed to know
that you had the work ethic
to go through the training that they
were going to have to go through knowing
that they were going to do their own
fighting and stunts
and so
I I cast by my gut and it was really
beautiful to read the script and know
immediately
I wanted LaShonda Lynch as a zogie like
there was nobody else
um and I wanted John boyegas the king
and that was both I didn't know either
of them I was just fans of the work and
fans of who they were as people just
based on so um this video that John had
had put out that went viral during the
um protests and Lashana a speech that
she gave at um at an award show that I
was at I just was so enamored by who she
was what she wanted to put in the world
what kind of work so
um and then I need to Define now we and
who how could I find a young woman
who really needed to go toe-to-toe with
Viola and tuso showed up in an audition
on my zoom screen we were you know at
that point obviously covet was affecting
everything and so it was just this face
that popped up and I like she didn't
even open her mouth yet and I fell in
love with her in that face those eyes
and then she started reading and her
chops are just insane and she was doing
things that no other actor was doing and
I felt everything and that was really
exciting I then had her meet with Viola
and they just talked for about 45
minutes and when they were finished
Viola told me I you know like I've never
met her before but I feel maternal
towards her wow
um and then the last part that tuzo had
to do
is that um she was honest which people
aren't often about when you say do you
have any athletic ability did you do any
sports growing up and she you know
honestly said no which was scary for me
sure
um so I I decided to have a stunned
assessment with her and Danny Hernandez
our incredible fight and stunt
coordinator took her to a gym and it was
supposed to be an hour of just going
through put a machete in her hand and
just give her combinations and
that hour turned to two because she just
wanted to keep learning she kept wanting
to get better she was like you could see
this kind of obsessive thing with her
and that just enamored us with her and
we knew that that attitude was what we
needed for her and then lastly um she
lets him who plays in menza incredible
and this is a beautiful thing because
Terry was cutting Halle Berry's
directorial debut bruised and Terry's
the one that said I found your menza
um and so they invited me to see an
early screening of the film and I loved
the film but literally when it finished
I was like who is that and it was Sheila
who was playing this incredible
character and it was absolutely yeah
she's our menza so it was a it was a
beautiful thing to put this group
together
and they bonded so quickly because they
were training to get together and doing
this intense months-long training that
was the hardest thing that any of them
had ever done but what it did is it
bonded them because they were
competitive with each other in the best
way but they also pushed each other
helped each other lifted each other
through all of that and
I knew that's what it would do it's it's
it I felt the best way I could build a
true Sisterhood amongst them what was
John doing while they were doing all
that training John was watching and
applauding and cheering them on
and walking around in his robes he loved
he truly loved the robes I would yeah
I'm I'm guessing some of these people
maybe kept their costumes I would try to
no they kept their weapons everybody
wanted their weapons that's so cool
well again it is such a beautiful movie
I want to thank you all so much for
being here I want to thank you for being
a great audience thank you thank you
everybody thank you